odessa 9h ce matin des familles
déplacées font déjà la file au soleil
pour des vêtements et de la nourriture
il arrive de l'est mais surtout ceux
comme des miraculés ils ont réussi à
fuir l'occupation russe à seulement 200
km et ce sont leurs villages leurs
patrimoines que l'armée ukrainienne
tente aujourd'hui de récupérer faut 6
anastasia et ses enfants vivent depuis
six mois en territoire contrôlé par les
russes près de milito paul l affût en
cachette il ya exactement une semaine
ma famille était en danger parce que mon
mari est un militaire dit
il restait pour se battre il participe
aujourd'hui à la vaste contre offensive
lancée par l'armée ukrainienne dans le
sud du pays
dommage le président volodymyr zelensky
hier soir avait lancé un ultimatum aux
soldats du kremlin capituler ou mourir
just got it de dôme
depuis de violents combats secouent la
région de personnes capturées par l'ami
russe au toubib l'évasion et nous avons
réussi ce matin à joindre ira
[Musique]
elle est barricadé dans son appartement
seul effrayé il
ya beaucoup d'explosions depuis deux
jours même au centre ville où elle dit
que les ukrainiens ont bombardé un
immeuble servait d'hôpital militaire à
l'armée russe
selon plusieurs sources l'armée
ukrainienne auraient percé la première
ligne du front russe libéré quelques
villages
[Musique]
alexander qui lui aussi de recel sonne
se morfond en attendant des nouvelles du
front et de ses enfants reconnaît
deux mots il appréhende le carnage et la
destruction de sa ville natale d'amara
s'ajoute à la discussion est pris pour
la libération personnes
elle est une survivante de mario paul et
dit qu'elle ne s'en remettra jamais
d'avoir a eu en terreau et sa nièce et
un bébé de quatre mois tout ce qu'on
veut c'est que ça finisse ne serait ce
que pour les enfants
ces enfants que la guerre suis même
quand il la fuit on leur a donné des
lego ils en font des fusils ici tamara
intéresse qu radio canada odessa